I mean I do the previews right.
We'll do the prelims.
Uh,
well I want to have that single cause.
Well I guess they're just,
the contract comes over like does everyone like the UFC tonight crew.
Everyone's like,
just check this over.
You have seen,
I was never working for Fox.
I didn't do the fire.
It was one of my one of these days.
Yeah.
But one of the stipulations of my newer contract decided don't want to do the
Fox events anymore and that deal through when you don't have to be done.
It's already done.
I mean it was a bit like this year.
I don't do any of the Fox events.
If you notice like when there are big fights on,
I know you don't do that.
Don't do any of them done the big ones?
Nope.
None of them.
Zero Justice paper.
If he's still doing it right.
Don't want to do anymore.
Too much work.
Too much work did this suit is not a big deal because they have the suit there
for me.
But the,
my issue was a fox actually paid me less money,
less money to do the fence on Fox.
I was like,
you guys are never paying you.
Yeah,
I thought the UFC Pagan,
no,
I get to Fox event.
It's a Fox event.
So,
um,
that,
but it was also,
I didn't like when I first started doing it for them,
they got in my ear like the very first events for Fox.
They were like telling me what to do.
They were like telling me to take it down a notch,
don't be so amped up about that.
Yay.
And I was like,
what?
What are we doing here?
I go,
listen,
I do commentary.
This is what I do.
I've been doing it forever.
This is how I do it.
If you think you can change me,
then we're not going to work together.
I'm like,
what a real problem.
And that was a fox deduction,
right Joe?
Yes.
It was a fox productions junior.
Dos Santos came the last case upon.
Yeah,
I believe that was the first one.
but it's just,
I just didn't,
I didn't like it.
They want a sports guy like,
look,
MMA is what it is.
It's,
it's fighting.
It is a very specific kind of sport and I've been doing it the way I do it
forever.
If you don't like the way I do it,
that's fine.
Don't hire me,
but don't try to get me to become some sports guy.
I'm not interested in that at all.
When I commentated for pride,
they told me,
I said,
Nice.
Too much.
No,
say Nice.
He was like,
no,
I couldn't even speak English.
I think Nice Shot,
Nice Jab.
To their credit,
they stopped.
They stopped doing it after the first event.
When I voiced my displeasure,
I just let them know like really clearly we're not going to do in this.
I'm not going to change how I do it to make you do this if I'm helping you.
It's not even that.
It's just like,
if you don't like the way I do it,
this is not an option for you to direct me and tell me to do it the way you like
it because you think that that's better.
This is a personal choice by one or two,
whoever the fuck the people were that were producers or executives,
I don't agree with them and I'm not doing it that way.
Like this is just how it,
it's like real simple.
Like if you bought a Ferrari and it had a certain sound to it,
you're like,
man,
I don't like this sound.
Can you guys go back to the factory and fix these mufflers?
They'd be like,
what do you,
hi,
this is what a Ferrari is like.
This is you don't like it.
Then you're like Ferrari's,
no,
no.
I like a for ride,
but I want it to sound like a Corola doesn't work.
They'd be like,
no.
Now you probably a bad analogy,
but the idea behind it,
you get,
I'm not,
this is what I do.
Like,
I get amped up if some shit is going down,
these guys were throwing blows and I'm screaming.
It's because I feel that way.
Some would call it passion.
Yeah.
It's bullets.
Legitimate Passion.
I'm not,
I'm not faking it,
but they didn't want that.
But they let it go after awhile.
But it's not like they fought for me when I quit either.
How long has the Reebok deal for?
Uh,
three years.
I think three years.
Two and three.
I wonder if it worked out for Reebok,
like his Reebok.
Reebok exploding now because of this.
Well,
Adidas owns Reebok to Adidas is killing it,
but I dunno.
Free box exploding.
They,
they're the niche,
right?
The MMA,
the therein with crossfit.
So they're in that world and to Reebok's defense,
you know,
they,
they made the offer.
They don't know.
They didn't know what the deal was.
They know they're screwing over fighters.
It's more of a UFC thing.
It was not Reebok Reebok,
it's like,
Whoa,
what the fuck?
It seemed like even the UFC wasn't aware of how much fight is we're actually
making off of sponsorships.